[Applaudissements]
m 2 c'est un collègue de travail
tout le monde te croyais mort il est
arrivé tellement de choses depuis notre
dernière rencontre
j'ai perdu mon marteau hier c'est tout
récent il faut encore que je m'en
remettre et loki le locking est toujours
en vie t'imagines série à aux lots qui
regarde tu es là je suppose que tu es là
[Musique]
je suis thor fils d'odin vraiment tu ne
lui ressemble en rien on peut sûrement
trouver un arrangement
toi tu parles comme l'i
à genoux et c'est à moi que tu parles
à genoux
[Musique]
devant votre rêve
hors de question
[Musique]
c'est impossible chérie tu n'as aucune
idée de ce qui est possible nous lie
yu na
bien
[Musique]
une forme
il s'est passé tant de choses depuis
notre dernière rencontre j'ai perdu mon
marteau
hier c'est tout récent je suis encore un
peu énervé
ensuite je suis parti en quête de moi
même
et c'est toi que j'ai trouvé
ou est ce qu'on est si tu savais hélas
la déesse de la mort envahisse garda
j'attendais ça depuis si longtemps
je sais on s'est battu l'autre jour et
j'ai gagné
non j'ai gagné facile tu es sûr de toi
t'as perdu
c'est tout
as garde est morte
elle remettra bientôt à mon niveau
on est dedans pas contents de me voir
il nous faut l'arrêter au plus vite pour
empêcher le raid maroc la fin de toute
chose
donc je met sur pied une équipe
comme au bon vieux temps
surprise on va bien s'amuser
[Musique]
salut salut
vrai guerrier
je suis une vraie
je suis la déesse de la mort
et toi de quoi était le dieu au juste
on se ressemble tous et moi de têtes
brûlées qui agissent sans réfléchir oui
on est les mêmes hulk comme le feu et or
quand je dirais qu'on est tous les deux
comme le feu et le quai comme ceux en
furie et tort comme des petites breizh
le spectacle commence
[Applaudissements]
baa top bleu fait complètement on a
embarqué dans un truc complètement
génial c'était vraiment ouais c'est l'un
des meilleurs avec gardiens de la
galaxie là pour l'instant
j'étais très très bien ça vaut le coût
réel pour les répliques d'aller voir on
se connaît bien
c'est un collègue de travail j'ai bien
kiffé y ait beaucoup d'humour mais par
son âge et son vol je trouve ça
tellement rafraîchissant
je trouve que c'est un film original
franchement c'était vraiment bien j'ai
retrouverons le tort des bd originale
voilà je suis comme un gosse l'humour la
musique
la réal aussi c'est incroyable cdc a
donné un coup de jane de ouf c'est
vraiment cool quand on est plus dans ces
super héros qui était figé dans des
postures bas que héroïque justement
maintenant un peu plus humain et rigole
il ya des rêves pleins de rêves aux
anciens marvel est ouverte acculèrent
super bien travaillé il ya des spéciaux
et tout c'était grandiose c'est vraiment
du grand israël dix ans il arrive encore
encore à se renouveler
c'est génial corps
je sais ce que vous pensez
comment c'est arrivé
c'est une longue histoire
[Musique]
as garde est morte
salut
que tu as porté cette fois un adversaire
[Musique]
spectacle commence
et
made man
je vous présente plus ni le croyant
[Applaudissements]
on se connaît bien
c'est un collègue de travail c'est quoi
way
[Musique]